We've all thought about disasters, imagined
massive floods, fires, or a meteor crashing
into Earth.
But what happens when the destruction comes
quietly and suddenly, with the dawning of
a new day?
Over the next 24 hours, the world as we all
know it will crumble, and something strange
and terrible will rise to take its place.
What will that look like?
Who will try to rise to the occasion and help,
and who will cower in the dark?
What happens to the people around the world
in the first 24 hours after Day Breaks?
Let's find out.
Hour 1
It's 6 AM on a farm in Kansas, and the land
is just beginning to wake up.
The farmer and his wife and children are still
sleeping, waiting for the cry of their rooster
to tell them that it's time to start the day.
The cows are grazing in the open field, letting
out the occasional half-hearted "moo," but
they're still a bit too sleepy to give it
their all.
The pigs snort restlessly in the barn, feeling
breakfast time approaching.
The rooster, proud and stately, hops onto
the roof of the chicken coop, surveying his
domain.
He tilts his head back and lets out a mighty
crow.
Cock-a-doodle...the sound catches in his throat
as something strange begins to happen.
His beak softens, like wax dripping from a
lit candle.
It drops to the ground with a soft plop as
his mighty wake-up call fades to a gurgle.
There is something wrong this morning, something
truly, deeply wrong.
If the rooster were capable of complex thought,
he would be terrified.
Instead, he is just melting, along with the
hens, the cows, and the pigs, all dripping
onto the grass as the faint light of morning
changes them.
Inside the farmhouse, the family begins to
scream.
Hour 2
An hour later, in New York City, the city
that never sleeps gets a rude awakening.
No one can be sure when exactly the chaos
broke out, but all of a sudden people in their
little apartments wake to the sound of masses
of people calling out for help, of the thunderous
footsteps of crowds tearing through the streets,
and then...of a strange gurgling sound that
replaces the bedlam.
A young woman throws open her blackout curtains
to get a better look, and finds herself melting
along with them.
Across town, a landlord knocks on his tenant's
door, demanding some overdue rent, but there
is no answer.
Only the slop of something oozing across the
floor inside.
Security footage of Times Square catches an
eerie sight, masses of molten flesh spreading
across the streets, the masses of tourists
that were gathered there only hours before
melted together into something else, bathed
in the neon glow of the billboards and lights
of the city.
Hour 3
On the other side of the world, in Canberra,
Australia, a group of college students is
camping in the wilderness.
While the United States is waking up to a
horror show, they are sleeping soundly in
their tents beneath the light of the moon.
Well, except for one of them, who had decided
to take his sleeping bag outside and sleep
under the stars.
That would have been a lovely idea, except
for the fact that all sunlight, including
that which reflected off the moon, has become
quite destructive to the human body.
To all living things, in fact.
His melted form sloshes around inside the
sleeping bag, trying to regain some semblance
of its original shape.
Inside their tent, his friends are still themselves,
shielded remarkably well from the light by
the thick canvas.
That is, until one of them gets up to go to
the bathroom, and unzips the front of the
tent.
His mouth is already useless by the time he
thinks to scream, and the moonlight floods
inside and covers the group in a silvery glow.
It doesn't take long for them to meet the
same fate as their friend outside, melting
together into one massive entity.
They had hoped this camping trip would bring
them closer together, and, well...it did.
Hour 4
Meanwhile, a speleologist is deep in the bowels
of a cave in Tian Shan that she has been studying,
completely unaware of the terrors of the surface.
She's taking samples, dictating notes to her
research assistant, and keeping an eye out
for bats, when suddenly, she receives a communication
from one of the members of her research team
up above.
The technology they use only allows for short
text messages that can be transmitted through
the layers of soil and rock all around, but
this warning needs only a few words: "Don't
come up.
Not safe."
The words send a chill up her spine.
What could possibly be happening that's more
dangerous than being down here?
She writes back, asking for clarification,
but receives none.
Through the dark tunnels, illuminated only
by a few headlamps, she thinks she can hear
the echo of a scream.
Hour 5
Those that are still safe, and have managed
to hold onto their identities and forms, have
noticed yet another threat in addition to
whatever the light is doing.
All around the world, planes are dropping
from the sky, their pilots and crews transformed
into something incapable of flying an aircraft.
Airplanes that were en route to their various
destinations, thousands of them going in every
direction imaginable, are now plummeting toward
the ground, crashing into the ocean, or, in
some especially unlucky cases, landing on
buildings that still have survivors inside.
It's a truly brutal bit of irony, to escape
the sun's terrible rays and find some small
sanctuary, only to have a plane fall out of
the sky and destroy it all.
Hour 6
Over at the SCP Foundation, everyone is on
high alert, trying to categorize what is happening
and find a way to stop it.
But how do you contain an anomaly when that
anomaly is the sun itself?
In the meantime, the O5 Council retreats to
a specialized underground bunker constructed
especially for this kind of dire scenario,
outfitted with beds, reading materials, and
enough supplies to keep them alive for several
years, as long as no one hogs the snacks.
As the rest of the Foundation staff scramble
to find a solution before the rest of the
Earth's population is reduced to goo, the
anomalies contained throughout the various
sites begin to take notice.
SCP-999 oozes frantically around its site,
hugging and nuzzling anyone it can get close
to.
It doesn't fully understand what is going
on, but it can tell that everyone is quite
upset and frightened by something, and it
wants to help them feel better.
Other anomalies have a less charitable approach.
SCP-173 takes advantage of the chaos to escape
containment, snapping a few necks on its way
out just for fun.
After all, everyone's eyes are otherwise occupied.
Because it is not made from any organic material,
it is immune to the effects of the sun, and
makes its way outside to explore the pandemonium.
Research staff that pass by SCP-682's containment
chamber can hear the giant beast chuckling
to itself, a sickening, choking sound as it
laughs at the fall of humanity.
"Finally..."
It sighs.
One scientist peeking in through the observation
window swears that the hard to destroy reptile
is smiling, before one of his colleagues ushers
him down the hall, away from the monster's
celebration.
SCP-507 appears in the hall with a pop, back
from another one of his involuntary inter-dimensional
voyages.
"Woah, where's the fire?"
He asks, taking in the hysteria around him.
"Did something get out?"
A bit of unease creeps into his voice.
"No!"
Shouts a passing guard.
"It's what's trying to get in."
"God!
I have the worst timing!"
507 groans.
Hour 7
Back in the realm of civilians, newscasters
hop on to broadcast from studios devoid of
natural light, unsure if there are any survivors
left to hear their messages.
One television personality forces his usual
bright smile, staring down the barrel of the
camera with barely-concealed tears in his
eyes.
He can't let his smile crack, can't let himself
break down.
If he lets himself cry, really cry, he's scared
he won't be able to stop.
"Please remain calm."
He reads off the teleprompter, as a production
assistant sobs into the shoulder of the camera
operator.
"Experts are working to determine what is
going on.
In the meantime, please follow these instructions
to ensure your safety, and that of your loved
ones: Do not go outside, unless you are covered
in proper equipment to shield yourself from
the sun or moon.
Block all sources of natural light in your
residence.
Do not attempt to interact with those who
have been affected by this disaster, do not
touch them, do not let them into your home,
do not speak to them.
Again, please remain calm.
Help is on the way."
He doesn't know if the words are true, he
only knows that it's his responsibility to
give the people hope, something familiar they
can turn to when nothing makes sense.
The camera switches off.
He covers his face and lets the tears loose.
Hour 8
In spite of the pleas from newscasters, people
are very much panicking.
How could they not?
Everything's descended into absolute mayhem
and it's only been eight hours since it all
began.
Unfortunately, where there is panic, there's
someone trying to make a quick buck off of
their fellow man.
Even more unfortunately, the internet is still
up and running so far, and with survivors
taking to social media to livetweet their
experiences and post as much as they can on
Instagram, Facebook, and anywhere else they
can reach out for help, it's the perfect environment
for scammers.
A Twitter thread goes viral, claiming that
wrapping oneself in aluminum foil will protect
against the effects of the light.
Facebook posts circulate, hawking all sorts
of natural remedies and "super sunscreens"
from essential oil blends to bacon grease.
A fraudulent GoFundMe page pops up, claiming
to belong to a climate scientist raising money
for a ray gun that will reverse the damage
done to the Earth's atmosphere, which he cites
as the cause of the destruction.
Hour 9
Not all of the information circulating online
is false, however.
A video is posted on TikTok with the caption
"these mofos can TALK!!!!!"
featuring video of a teenage boy cowering
in a dark room as one of the formerly human
flesh creatures moves around outside the door.
After a moment or two of silence, a garbled
voice calls out to him "Brian...come outside...please,
come out into the sun...I miss you..."
The video's comments are filled with other
users sharing similar experiences, saying
"It talked just like my boyfriend!"
"It barked like a dog!" or even "It was singing
my favorite Ariana Grande song."
Similar videos pop up in the wake of this
first recording, urging survivors to ignore
the voices, no matter who they seem like they
belong to.
Hour 10
While some people are using the internet to
spread helpful information on the nature of
the events outside, others have ruled out
rational explanations entirely, claiming that
this is a divine punishment for the sins of
mankind, or the Matrix finally collapsing
in on itself.
Others deny that the horrible events are even
happening at all.
An infamously contrarian Livestream personality
logs on from his insulated basement, crowing
to his viewers that "None of this is actually
happening.
It's all a ploy to keep us complacent and
under government control.
As yourself, why don't they want us going
outside?
So we don't see what they're really up to."
As commenters try desperately to change his
mind, he doubles down.
"You're all a bunch of sheeple.
Baa!
Baa!"
He laughs.
"Look, I'll show you that there's nothing
to worry about."
He carries his laptop upstairs with him, and
steps outside onto the sidewalk.
In his computer screen, he can see the video
feed of his own face beginning to droop and
liquefy before he can even feel it.
He tries to run back inside, away from the
light, but it's too late.
His legs are already giving out.
The viewers can only watch as their favorite
streamer dissolves in real-time, until his
now-useless hands drop the laptop to the ground,
where it breaks into pieces, and the stream
goes dark.
For those who have survived this long, at
the 12-hour mark, things are beginning to
get tense.
Actually, that would be an understatement.
Tensions have been bubbling steadily for the
past twelve hours as people have melted into
unrecognizable waxy monsters, exploded in
plane crashes, and been traumatized to within
an inch of their lives.
Now, those tensions are boiling over.
Human beings in a crisis can be a bit like
crabs in a bucket, vicious and ready to tear
each other to pieces if they perceive that
they might be left behind.
When there is a shortage of resources, this
selfish fear and anger only get worse.
Hour 13
There might not be a lack of food or fresh
water yet, but there is another resource that
seems worth destroying each other for: darkness.
In a world where light means death, the only
safe place is in the dark.
But there are a limited number of places that
people can go.
In rural areas, families retreat to storm
cellars or the insides of empty grain silos.
In cities, underground parking garages become
hiding places, and there just isn't enough
space there to go around.
People erupt into physical fights in these
parking complexes, punching and shoving each
other, even attacking with broken bottles
and other improvised weapons, all to stake
their claim over this newfound territory.
Even more contentious are warehouses, insulated
hiding places filled with all of the supplies
that will soon start to dwindle: toilet paper,
canned goods, soap, and bottled water.
These things just might be worth killing for,
and many are already prepared to do so.
Hour 14
While the SCP Foundation is busy trying to
maintain order and find a way to end this
catastrophic event, other groups dedicated
to the anomalous are equally busy.
The Chaos Insurgency attempt to launch a sneak
attack on Site-19 while its occupants are
distracted.
However, their defenses against the sun prove
ineffective, and they are melted before they
can so much as reach the Site's entrance.
Inside, the Foundation staff never even notice.
They've got far too much on their hands already.
Other groups take a less offensive approach,
prioritizing safety.
Members of the Serpent’s Hand escape to
the interdimensional Wanderer's Library along
with their families, settling in for the long
haul and preparing to make it their permanent
home as the Earth burns.
They didn't want it to end this way, but they're
not going to stick around to be a part of
it all.
Hour 18
Not all people are turning on each other,
even as things appear dire.
The best thing anyone can do in a horrible
situation is to look for those willing to
extend a helping hand.
There will always be people trying to look
out for others, to put out the fires, and
airlift people out of the flood waters.
Though this disaster seems anything but natural,
the instinct to help is still there for many.
Doctors and nurses hole up in hospitals, blocking
out the windows with spare pairs of scrubs
and whatever else they can find to light-proof
the building.
There, they treat the wounded that make it
inside, wrapping broken bones and stitching
up wounds as best they can.
A few well-intentioned souls even attempt
to treat those changed by the sun, those things
that barely look human anymore, no matter
how hard they try to arrange their soft bodies
back into their former shape.
It's too late for them, though.
There's nothing to be done, and no medical
school in the world could have prepared a
doctor to heal this hurt.
But what about the people who aren't all the
way gone?
The ones who started to change, but got inside
in time to slow, or even stop, the process?
Hospital staff treat the melting like an infection,
amputating molten limbs or attempting to clean
and bandage them, unsure of what to do with
a piece of the human body that no longer behaves
like flesh and bone.
They're able to save a few people, but far
more are already doomed by the time they make
it inside.
They disintegrate slowly, but steadily, fading
away on the operating table until their warbling
voices are urging the doctors to follow them
outside.
"It doesn't hurt..."
They promise, reaching out with fleshy tentacles
that once were hands.
It's hard to remember the Hippocratic oath
when a monster is trying to pull you into
its grasp.
Hour 20
While some are trying to help the creatures
created by the sun's wrath, others have been
waiting for this moment since they saw their
very first zombie movie.
To them, this is an outbreak, plain and simple,
and it's the perfect chance to suit up and
play soldier.
They cloak themselves in body armor and helmets
with dark tinted visors, and grab whatever
weapons they can find.
Grenades, firearms, flamethrowers, anything
is fair game at the end of the world.
A former police officer and massive fan of
zombie-themed first-person shooters takes
to the streets, staring down an enormous mound
of flesh made from dozens of people melding
together, ropy tentacles flailing and grasping
for more bodies to add to its mass.
He fires an array of bullets into the thing,
but they are absorbed into its surface, swallowed
up inside.
He searches for weak points, for eyes, a heart,
anything he can target, but he can't spot
anything vulnerable.
But he's not deterred, he'll try fire next.
He lights a homemade Molotov cocktail and
hurls it at the beast, waiting for it to ignite
and listening for the sound of its painful
cries.
But nothing comes.
The cocktail explodes, and nearby debris catches
on fire, but the ball of flesh doesn't react.
It just continues to advance toward him, making
its way down the street as if it has all the
time in the world.
There's only one option left, and it's the
riskiest one of all.
He pulls out a grenade, and pulls the pin.
Throwing it won't do, he needs to run up and
thrust the grenade into the body of the monster,
to blow it up from inside.
He's going to have to be quick.
He summons all of the stamina from his high
school track and field days and makes a mad
sprint for the creature, holding the grenade
out in front of him.
Eyes on the prize, there is nothing but the
mission now.
The chance to be a hero.
He is so singularly focused on his task, that
he doesn't notice a tentacle snaking along
the ground toward him until it loops around
his feet, flipping him over until he's upside
down.
The force of the movement knocks his helmet
loose, and it falls to the ground below.
He moves to shield his face with his hands,
but it's useless.
The sunlight has already found him.
He is already changing, becoming one with
the very thing he promised to destroy.
He stares up at the mass with reverence, just
before his eyes drop out of his head, and
reaches his arms out to welcome its embrace.
By the time the grenade detonates, he can't
bring himself to care about it.
He can't care about anything, except being
a part of the flesh.
Hour 22
If individuals have a tendency to blame each
other in times of strife, then governments
are even worse.
Surviving leaders of various countries, shivering
in their bunkers and tearing out their hair
with stress, begin to convince themselves
that this must be some kind of act of biological
warfare gone wrong.
Nuclear testing, some kind of deadly gas,
something.
Surely, ruination on this grand of a scale
must be man-made.
With no other recourse, they begin declaring
war on each other, everyone pointing a finger
at someone else as no one is able to take
responsibility.
The threats, the denials, and the rage escalate
until finally, the North Korean government
makes a decision that would seem completely
insane under any other circumstances: they
attempt to nuke the sun.
It's irrational, and it's ineffective, of
course, but it's the last gasp of a species
hurtling toward extinction.
One final attempt to bring it all to an end,
before it's all truly over.
Hour 24
And as the dust clears, it becomes completely
apparent: the old world is dead.
And a new world, for better, or for much,
much worse, is born.
Nothing will ever be the same again.
Now go check out "SCP-001 When Day Breaks
Dr Bright" and "When Day Breaks SCP-035" for
more of everyone’s favorite apocalypse!